[Music]
some of you are aware I saw some signs
but I just wanted to let everyone out
there know it's your birthday
[Applause]
with a hug the
thank you that's very nice thank you
very much just pass your gifts forward
Wow
not one huh no I I that's that's really
nice and and by the way thanks for
putting together that that office party
earlier today that was a that was a nice
gesture Thanks you know uh or on the
subject you could have been a little
more gracious about it I'm just I'm not
great on birthdays you know who's not
okay but you were a jerk I was not a
jerk you know I might have been a little
bit cranky but I don't remember being
[Applause]
you guys here he comes here he comes be
quiet surprise for he's a jolly good
fellow for he's a jolly good fellow
hey come on damn it Andy I told you not
to do this we just wanted to wish you a
happy birthday
hey man yay you know I get embarrassed
by all this attention now let's get
downstairs to tape an episode of my talk
show Conan come on corn and you're
bumming everybody out just have a piece
of cake I don't want any cake we went
through all this trouble I mean at least
look at the cake oh it's just the cake
look at that happy birthday Conan can't
even spell my name right
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
I I guess I could have handled that
better a couple hours ago yeah I guess
you could have yeah well anyway I I
think you could have reacted a little
better - all right you're right I mean
as long as we're apologizing I guess I
should apologize for what happened
afterward yeah I think you should
apologize for what happened afterwards
[Applause]
[Music]
so this is the cake happy birthday
Konan
you can't even spell my name right I
hate this I hate you people
you son-of-a-bitch just calm down Andy
take it easy God a person does that you
a cape
[Applause]